so today we're going to teach you how to
diagnose the inside of your body your
health
using your face
but i need to tell you something
how can i put this
you don't want to start
diagnosing your friends
especially your family especially your
spouse using what i'm about to teach you
the worst thing you can do with other
people is basically to tell them
what their problems are unless
you know they're paying you like in
practice for 30 years
or they ask you
so use this information
on yourself because the last thing i
want you to do
is to start to
explain to your spouse hey honey i just
learned why you have a round face and
why you have bags underneath your eyes
and you have scaly rough skin
and then you mentioned dr berg in the
same sentence
bad idea don't do it and it's bad
manners and it's just you're asking for
a fight so use this information for
yourself
all right so let's take a look at what's
going on here
let's say
you're balding right usually a loss of
hair on the top part of your head means
you have too much dht dht is a very
powerful form of testosterone
that is occurring because
there's this enzyme that is converting
testosterone into dht at a higher level
than it should be and so what you want
to do is you want to
reduce this enzyme by taking certain
inhibitors okay and those inhibitors
come in pumpkin seeds green tea
and zinc will help you lower this enzyme
to help lower dht i have a lot more
information on this but i'm going to
give you the the big overview and the
concepts not the specifics all right so
if you're losing your eyebrows on the
outer part that is a hypothyroid issue
slow thyroid you might need some iodine
okay next thing is bloodshot eyes that's
usually a liver problem now it could be
that you
got drunk the night before and you have
a hangover and you have bloodshed eyes
but it's either something related to the
liver
that is usually coming from your diet
i've noticed in the past not recent past
a long time ago when i ate poorly
a lot of junk food my eyes were always
bloodshot so bloodshy eyes mean stress
in the liver but it can also mean
especially if it's red on the inside of
your eyelids
you have a blood sugar problem okay
you're eating too many carbs i used to
have that and you can also feel like
sandpaper too
so if there's irritability on the inside
of your eyelids
suspect you have insulin problems you
have insulin resistance and you're
pre-diabetic or heading in that
direction now i am going to cover um
what's behind dry eyes in a little bit
so let's go on to the next one darkened
circles underneath the eyes if you have
these dark circles
that is a pigment problem coming from
insulin resistance a lot of diabetics
have this and they also get dark in
pigments in different places in the body
different folds and their armpits on
their neck
that comes from high levels of insulin
which is affecting melanin in the body
okay so
if you have darkened circles underneath
the eyes there it's what you have to do
is you have to get on healthy keto and
do intermittent fasting to help produce
this insulin resistance situation now
let's flip right over here
to these bags beneath the eyes
okay if you get these like this swollen
uh tissue underneath the eye or or even
on top of the eye
this is either a blood sugar issue same
thing
or there's something going on with the
kidney now the thing that destroys the
kidney more than anything is high levels
of sugar so it does relate to insulin
resistance because the kidney is one
organ that gets hammered with a high
carb diet but there's other causes of
kidney problems as well
but if the kidney is backed up with
fluid you'll see it underneath the eye
it'll just be swollen now let's kind of
go through this side here oily skin
that means that your
oil glands sebaceous glands are pumping
out too much oil because your androgens
are too high and if you're male
you need more zinc to help regulate the
amount of estrogen now if you're female
it could also mean that you need more
zinc but usually if you have too much
androgen in your female you have
something called polycystic ovarian
syndrome and you might have other
additional symptoms like facial hair
acne which is high levels of androgen
which is coming from
this insulin okay high levels of insulin
because the carbs are too high
are you starting to see a common thread
so far
a high carbohydrate diet also depletes
zinc
allowing the
antigens to go higher if you are a
female so there's a lot of issues with
skin related to insulin
oily skin
acne
and the list goes on okay let's talk
about cataracts
cataracts occur when the lens of the eye
becomes opaque and you can no longer see
through it and the lens is very very
sensitive
to oxidation
and where would you get oxidation you
can get it from you know looking into
the sun you can get it from chemicals
you can get it from taking steroids and
other medication
but a very common cause would be if
you're consuming a high carb diet this
is why the incidence of getting a
cataract if you're a diabetic is very
very high also if you're deficient in
vitamin a you're more susceptible to
cataracts
what happens when you eat a lot of carbs
without the antioxidants without the
protective mechanism you get a lot of
free radical damage you get a lot of
oxidation and you have symptoms you
might have peripheral neuropathy in your
feet you might have cataracts you might
have problems with the retina you might
have problems with your heart
so there's a very good remedy if you're
starting to get cataracts to help
reverse it
vitamin b1 in the form
of a fat-soluble version which is called
ben photome that acts as a powerful
antioxidant to help counter the
collateral damage from the high level of
blood sugars if you're a diabetic so
vitamin b1
as benfotamine will greatly help slow
down and possibly reverse
cataracts there's some other things you
can take to that can act as a very
powerful antioxidant nac drops okay it
comes in a liquid you take that you put
in your eyes and it helps to protect all
the free radical damage that's occurring
all right the next thing is red cheeks
okay so you have these like either
rosacea or red cheeks
you see they're quite common
you see this in cushing's syndrome
cushing's syndrome is a high level of
cortisol okay that person is under a lot
of stress
and that's one of the symptoms
but the treatment for red cheeks
medically
is giving a person an antibiotic now why
would an antibiotic work for red cheeks
well obviously there's some type of
microbial imbalance going on why not
give the person a
natural antibiotic like garlic oregano
thyme
wormwood extract
sage there's a lot of different herbs
you can take as a natural antibiotic and
then give the person
probiotics
what's the best probiotic sauerkraut
because it has the prebiotic and the
probiotic but you can also take
probiotics as a supplement but it's been
very effective to help this redness in
the cheeks
now if someone has either a gray or
brownish
pigmentation on the cheek that's
something a little different it's called
melasma and melasma
is an estrogen problem you're taking too
much estrogen or you're being exposed to
too much estrogen either in a birth
control pill or some type of hormone
replacement therapy
or it could be coming from exposure to
you know a lot of plastics in the
environment or certain chemicals that
can mimic estrogen
so if this is you what you want to do is
you want to take
something that can actually oppose that
or help clean it up and
dim is a good remedy which is a
concentrated form of cruciferous
or start to consume more cruciferous
foods
or iodine in the form of sea kelp can
help balance
estrogen now what about all this this
scaly peeling type
flaky skin that you get around the nose
okay
or in the ear okay what is that
that is a combination of low omega-3
fatty acids
and high omega-6 fatty acids
normally you want a one-to-one ratio
very few people
have that ratio there's a really good
test that you can do you can actually
they send you a kit and i'll put a link
down below but they send you a kit you
take a drop of your blood you send it
off and they can tell you your ratios of
how much omega-3 versus how much omega-6
and
quite a few people have a severe
imbalance and they're just really heavy
on the six and low on the three
so that means they need to consume
more
cod liver oil
fatty fish to bring these back in
balance but if you have this imbalance
you'll have rough scaly skin
dermatitis
a lot of skin issues inflammation of the
skin
dry eyes and dry hair
now what foods are high in omega-6
chicken
and fried foods as in fried in corn oil
soy oil canola oil
those type of oils which are very high
in the omega-6
range including peanut oil as well now
safflower oil and sunflower oil are also
omega-6
but they're much better because they're
not gmo however you don't want to
consume a lot of them a little bit here
and there is going to be fine but most
people just need to dramatically
increase their omega 3 fatty acids if
you're a vegan you can get your omega-3
from algae
and some other sources like that
also
nuts and nut butters like in peanut
butter in grains are very high in six
low in three this is why cows that are
fed grains
don't have the right ratios of omega-3
to omega-6. same thing with other
animals that are meant to consume grass
but typically
a lot of teenagers
you know they eat junk food they don't
eat a lot of vegetables they don't eat
fish they don't eat cod liver oil they
have skin issues okay they have a lot of
skin issues you'll see it around here
a lot of times they will have also oily
skin they'll have acne and so
they can clean this up if they have this
knowledge boy when i was a teenager i
had a lot of these issues and i wished i
had someone to actually tell me what to
do and give me the correct knowledge so
i wouldn't have to go through that
what we're looking at is a lot of
different
symptoms and indicators that give clues
to help us pull the string to see what's
behind it but unfortunately when you
look up each one of these symptoms
online especially on the first five
pages of google
you're going to find a lot of medical
type recommendations medications creams
and they're not going to tell you the
deeper causes all right let's talk about
blackheads
blackheads
it's a simple vitamin d deficiency if
you're low in vitamin d
you get blackheads okay so get some more
sun
watch my video on how to create your own
vitamin d supplement from mushrooms
exposing it to sun
or take it as a supplement
okay cracked corners of your mouth right
here and i i've had that i've had a lot
of these symptoms in the past
okay cracks that's a b2 deficiency
vitamin b2 prevents the liver from
becoming damaged it does a lot of other
things as well but one thing it will do
it affects the skin and it creates
fissures okay and those fissures or
cracks also can cause chap lips
and also can cause cracked heels on the
back of your heels you'll get these
little cracks that's a b2 deficiency
coming from consuming too much refined
flour usually okay and that would be in
the form of like breads pasta cereal
crackers biscuits
pancakes things like that
now when you see coal sores okay
that is herpes simplex one that is a
virus
and the best way to put that thing back
in remission is to take a natural
herb or
or something that is anti-viral like
garlic
like zinc
but there's been some great data on
fasting periodic prolonged fasting that
can help get rid of certain viruses the
problem with viruses is a lot of these
viruses stay in your body and they go
into a dormant state and they wait until
your immune system is weak and they come
out and kick you when you're down when
you get older when you're nutritionally
deficient and especially when you go
through stress
one of the biggest stresses that causes
viruses to come out of remission
is
losses
so
sooner or later we're all going to
experience losses people around us that
we love we're going to lose them and so
that stress can really hit the body and
cause these viruses to come out of
remission in fact
a lot of autoimmune diseases also are
triggered by severe stress in the form
of losses so that is one area that you
don't see a lot of information
but i've seen it in my practice
almost one for one i always ask people
what happened right before you got this
autoimmune disease or what happened
right before you got sick or had this
virus come out of remission and there's
usually always some type of stress event
or some type of loss okay facial hair
okay we talked about that a female that
means too much androgens could be
polycystic ovarian syndrome and
the way that you get too much androgens
is by having too much insulin so again
the common theme is to
go low carb and not eating so frequently
as in doing intermittent fasting all
right acne i already mentioned this but
both females and males it's too much
androgens now it could be too much
estrogen as well
but typically it's going to be
too much androgen and that usually comes
from too much insulin now other things
can cause acne too like drinking milk
but it's not as common as this insulin
problem right and so what you need to do
is you just need to get off the carbs
clean up the diet and this acne will go
away but the acne is a real good
indicator on what's going on with
someone's diet but boy i wish i would
have known what to do back in
high school when i had bad acne because
it can be devastating all right last
point
you can see this little line here a
round face
i'm gonna put up a picture of
when my son got married you can see the
shape of my head was
roundish compared to now that was
because
i was on a so-called healthy
diet but that healthy diet include
apples as snacks
with peanut butter i wasn't eating like
completely junk food but i was eating
fruit and i was having a lot of snacks
so if you have a brown face and you want
to
kind of strip off some of the fat or the
puffiness
and handle a lot of these other issues
you get on a healthy keto diet you stop
snacking you do intermittent fasting and
if you are new to my channel i have
two very simple videos to watch in a row
and i put them up right here check it
out